wait for the talk I'm actually going to
spend about half the talk depending on
your background either introducing or
reminding you of some of the challenges
in multi-item mechanism design and then
in the second half I'll get to our
results which is a new duality framework
to address these challenges and the
whole talk is going to be pretty light
on proof details if you happen to be
around next week i'm giving a the
whiteboard seminar where i'll give
complete proofs of everything ok so we
actually saw this model in both of the
two previous talks but let me remind you
of it to be sure so say you have just a
single item that you're trying to sell
to a single buyer and you don't know the
buyers valuation but you do know that he
comes from some population and you have
good aggregate information about this
population so how do you sell your item
while you announce a menu what's a menu
it has a list of options every option
has a price and a corresponding
probability and then what happens is
this buyer walks in your door he has
some value drawn from this population
and he selects whatever menu option
maximizes his expected utility and his
utility is just the value times the
probability he gets the item minus the
price he would have to pay ok and so
your goal is the seller is to maximize
your expected revenues this is just in
expectation over buyers walking in your
door the amount that they will choose to
pay you based on your menu ok and Nicole
already mentioned this but the seminal
result for this really simple model is
due to myosin and Riley and Zach Houser
which shows at the optimal menu even
though it could in principle be
randomized doesn't need to use the
randomization ok so the only two options
on the menu are you pay nothing and you
get nothing or you pay some price and
you get the item with probability 1
what's this price it's literally just
finding the optimal price and so the
revenue of sending any given price is
that price times the probability that a
buyer who walks in your door will choose
to pay it ok so that setting is really
simple let's um generalize a little bit
to one item in multiple bidders how you
should parse this is that there's a you
know many different bidders who are
going to walk in your door at the same
time maybe you know something about them
and that's modeled as they come from
different populations so maybe you know
that bitter one is a junior faculty
somewhere you're not sure that it's yang
exactly and maybe you know that you know
the third bidder is definitely someone
from Seattle but you're not positive
it's nikhil ok so what do you do when
these buyers walk in you announce
mechanism a mechanism just takes as
input a bid from every buyer it selects
a winner and it charges each bit or a
price without loss of generality you can
restrict attention to what are called
Beijing incentive compatible mechanisms
that just means it for every bitter it's
optimal for them to report their true
value conditioned on the other bidders
also reporting their true values and
okay good so then what happens is buyers
with values drawn from these populations
walk in your door they are incentivized
to tell the truth so they'll report
their true values to your mechanism and
right and then you'll get on some
revenue and your goal is again to
maximize your expected revenue so this
is just an expectation over people
walking in your door the amount that
they will choose to pay you ok and the
seminal result here is again due to
meyerson's work from 81 and he showed
that the optimal mechanism even with
many bidders still has this simple
format ok so let me go over the general
statement first so he shows that there
exists that what he calls virtual
transformations so for each population
there's a different transformation fee i
feei takes as input the bidders reported
bid and maps it to what he calls a
virtual bid ok and then the winner of
the auction is a bitter with the highest
non-negative virtual value ok so we
sometimes use this terminology we say
that the auction maximizes virtual
welfare because if these virtual bids
were the actual values of the bidders we
would be maximizing welfare ok so this
is how it chooses the winner the price
that it charges is what's called the
critical value which is just the minimum
bid that a buyer could make and still be
the winner
okay in this special case that all of
these populations happen to be the same
and they happen to satisfy a technical
condition called regularity so I've
written this here but it's actually not
important that you know it for this talk
then you can say something even stronger
about the optimal mechanism it's
actually just the second price auction
with reserves this is what you see if
you go and buy anything on ebay okay and
the reserve happens to be exactly the
same price that you would set if you
were just selling the Apple to one
bitter okay I also want to tell you
about a different seminal result that
maybe some of you are less familiar with
due to Boulogne Klemperer informally
what it says is that increased
competition is better than market
research okay so let me let's say that
you have two choices you can either keep
the number of bidders fixed if they're
all from the same population and this
population is regular you can learn the
optimal reserve by doing market research
or what you could do is you could just
convince one extra bitter to show up to
the auction and not do any research
whatsoever about the market and it turns
out that it's always better to just
convince one more person to show up to
the market than to learn anything about
it okay okay so in summary for one item
the situation is actually really nice so
we know that the optimal mechanism is
simple it's deterministic it happens to
satisfy a stronger notion of
truthfulness called dominant strategy
truthful and this is even though it's
competing with the best randomized
Beijing truthful mechanism okay so this
is really nice and we saw that
specialize 21 bitter it's really simple
it just sets a price for many iid
regular bidders it's a second price
auction with reserve so what we see on
ebay all the time and even in the most
general setting it still has this
somewhat nice structure okay so the
point is that we have really nice
results for a single item settings okay
now let me jump into multi-item settings
and we're going to see basically exactly
the opposite is true that even in really
simple multi-item settings a situation
is a bit of a mess
okay so before I do that let's be clear
about the model so it's the natural
extension as before there's some
population d / bidders who are going to
walk in your door the only difference is
they now have values for both the apple
and the orange instead of just the apple
okay so how would you sell these to one
bidder it's still the same you announce
a menu every option on the menu still
has a price it just now has a vector of
probabilities instead of just a
probability that you get the one item a
buyer with values is going to be drawn
from this population and walk in your
door he's going to choose whatever menu
option maximizes his expected utility
for this talk the buyers valuations are
going to be additive that just means
that their value for a set of items sums
our value for every item in that set so
the utility can be written in this form
and again your goal is just to maximize
your expected revenue so in expectation
over people walking in your door the
amount of money they choose to pay okay
so let's first try and reason about why
is this not a trivial problem okay so we
can maybe try to design the optimal
mechanism for this instance by going
through the following reasoning okay so
in this instance Young's values for both
fruits are drawn independently and
uniformly from the set 12 so we can try
to reason first that while Young's value
for the Apple actually doesn't change
depending on whether or not he gets the
orange because his values are additive
and even if we knew Young's value for
the orange that doesn't give us any
information about the Apple because his
values for the items are independent so
there's no dependency whatsoever between
the items from the buyers point of view
so it seems like maybe we should just
sell each item separately at the optimal
price which happens to be one we'd make
a revenue of one per item or two in
total and kind of the surprise is it
actually there's something flawed about
this reasoning and this is not optimal
and there's something better you can do
which is you can bundle the fruits
together and set a price of three okay
so by that I mean you can tell young you
can either pay three and get both the
Apple and the orange or pay nothing and
get nothing with probability
three-fourths he will choose to do this
so you make revenue nine fourths which
is better than two okay so this is
already a little bit surprising the
you have to be clever at all see things
get even weirder if we change the
examples so that now Young's value for
the Apple is drawn uniformly from the
set 13 in this example we know that the
unique optimal mechanism is randomized
ok so the unique optimal mechanism has
this form you have three options the
first is you get the Apple and the
orange and you pay for the second is you
get the Apple with probability 1 the
orange with probability a half and you
pay two and a half and the third is you
get nothing and pay nothing ok we also
know that things get even weirder so
there exist correlated distributions
over additive values for two items such
that the optimal randomized mechanism
has infinite revit gets infinite revenue
but the optimal deterministic mechanism
gets revenue upper bounded by one ok so
restricting yourself to deterministic
mechanisms could cost you an unbounded
fraction of the optimal revenue hey
let's also revisit compared to this
comparison between market research and
competition and let's say I told you
that you could either sell both fruits
optimally to one bitter whose values are
drawn from the population d or you could
recruit one extra bitter to show up but
then you have to run the second price
auction on each item separately ok so
here again it turns out that there are
correlated distributions it's the same
one from the previous example such that
for any finite number of bidders it is
better to just run the optimal mechanism
with one bitter than it is to recruit
any number of additional bidders ok so
if you get everyone in the world to show
up to your auction it's still better to
just learn the market and sell your two
fruits the only one person ok and even
if you're willing to make some strong
assumptions about the population so
maybe that it's a product distribution
and all the marginals are iid it could
still be the case that the optimal
mechanism for one bidder is better than
a second price auction for each item
separately for many additional bidders
okay the last time I don't want to talk
about is called non monotonicity okay so
let's say I told you you could sell your
two fruits to one of two populations
either F by F or F plus x f plus and I
told you that F plus so casta CLE
dominated f okay now if you are only
selling one fruit it would be really
clear that it's better to sell your one
fruit to F plus instead of F because for
whatever price you're thinking about
setting it is more likely to sell to the
market f + than f okay so you will
definitely get more revenue okay but we
can ask what if it's there's two items
in its f by f versus f + x f plus and it
turns out that sometimes you can get
more revenue from this strictly worse
distribution than the better one okay so
what this means is it right this is
should be somewhat surprising to you
write that even though everyone in the
market f + x f + likes both fruits
better than their a counterpart in f by
f you might make less revenue by selling
it to this strictly better market okay
so just to summarize what we saw for
multiple items is that the optimal
mechanism could be randomized and that
the best randomized mechanism could be
infinitely better than the best
deterministic one okay we saw that
market research could be better than
extra bidders even when the values are
IID we saw that you have this nut weird
non-monetary City phenomenon and I
didn't give an example for this but we
also know now that the best beige
incentive compatible mechanism is
actually strictly better than the best
dominant strategy truthful mechanism
okay so the solution concept matters
okay so at the point of this is just to
convince you there's a lot of
interesting stuff already going on just
with even just with one bitter and two
items okay so now with that let me just
take a side line and say like what
drives all of these nice single item
results that we have and in my opinion
what's driving all of them is that
Myerson seminal paper was a lot more
than just designing the optimal
mechanism from one setting he proved
this really nice theorem that says for
any Beijing truthful mechanism its
revenue is upper bounded by its virtual
welfare okay so what does this mean
this means formally that the expected
revenue that any truthful mechanism
obtains is upper bounded by the expected
virtual welfare of the winner okay I
didn't define this virtual welfare
function for you but just for whatever
it's defined this is what the theorem
says okay just to help give you a little
bit of intuition for what this right
hand side is it's clearly optimized if I
use the allocation rule that just finds
the bitter with the highest non-negative
virtual value and gives them the item
okay and it turns out that this is just
an extremely useful bound it happens to
be exactly attainable by meyerson's
mechanism this bound is exactly what
enables the Bulo Klemperer result and it
drives essentially every single item
result invasion settings okay and
apparently it even drives results did
you know like Nicole's talk that have
nothing to do with mechanism design as
well okay and so I just want to point
out it's not the case that you know once
you know meyerson's theorem it's trivial
to prove anything you want about single
item settings but the point is that once
you know meyerson's theorem you at least
have some place to start and then you
can do interesting work to prove
interesting things but I do think that
without meyerson's theorem there's just
not a good starting place to even
address any results like these okay and
so the comparison to multi-item settings
is it the comparable bound for
multi-item settings we just don't have
one yet okay and there's an asterisk
because I'm about to contradict this for
some special cases on the next slides
but in general we don't have a general
Myerson type theorem okay so what where
do we have bounds that are useful so the
first example is started from a seminal
paper of chawla hard line and Kleinberg
and together with follow-up work of
Chawla hardline malakin Sivan they
showed that a for a single unit demand
buyer whose values for the items are
drawn independently that item pricing
gets you for approximation okay so what
is unit demand it's very similar to
additive but just instead of summing
your values for each item when you get a
set of items you take your favorite one
instead an item pricing is exactly what
it sounds like you just post a price on
each item separately and the buyer takes
whatever they want okay so what's the
main tool i'm just going to say like two
sentences about it so they consider a
related single item setting so basically
they take the same input and they think
of the items as being bitters instead of
being as different items and now when
you think of a one item many bitter
setting you can use classical Myerson
theory to get upper bounds and
miraculously what they're able to show
is it upper bounds in this related
setting give you useful upper bounds in
the original setting ok so this approach
was successfully used in a lot of
follow-up works but I still want to
offer a critique which is that even
though this tool is clearly extremely
useful it's inherently limited to unit
the man bitters okay and so to date we
haven't been able to use this approach
and extend it beyond a unit demand
setting okay so there's a second line of
papers where we do know a quite a lot
and that started from a seminal work of
alcohol at seminole now of a hardon
nissan where they showed that for a
single additive buyer and values for
items are drawn independently that the
better of selling separately and selling
together gets you six approximation okay
and so these terms probably mean what
they sound like again so selling
separately just means you set the
optimal price on each item as if it was
the only item you let the buyer take
whatever subset they want and be arrived
means bundled together you just take all
the items as one you put a price on it
the buyer can take everything or nothing
okay and the main tool I can't say
anything really intelligent about this
is just a direct upper bound using
probabilistic tools we now call it the
core tail decomposition it has been
successfully used in follow-up works
beyond the single out of bitter setting
I still want to offer a critique of this
so again it's clearly an extremely
useful tool but really this
decomposition was tailored to work well
for a single additive bitter and even
though we've been able to use it for
settings beyond that it's very tricky to
use exactly this decomposition correctly
okay
okay so that's everything I was going to
say yep since you seem to be wrapping up
your literature review of techne where's
the hug pilot Hartline paper on
second-degree on price discrimination
okay good so so I think okay so there's
a missing related work slide that I
realized when I saw other talks related
work slides that I should have included
so what is missing is a discussion of
other duality approaches to mechanism
design so there is work by um hostess
Allen deco bombing Cristo Samos there's
another one by Elias katsu PS and
ammianus jian giannakopoulos I think and
then there's work of um Jason and Nima
and so I would describe so all three of
these approaches I would describe as
they get really really clean
characterizations again for special
cases so like Jason and Nima's approach
again is very specialized to the unit
demand setting and the other two duality
frameworks are specialized to the single
additive bitter settings i would say
what is um unique about our approach is
it on but we don't get as strong results
in specialized cases it applies much
more generally than just one bitter and
that's as far as I know the only one
where we can prove approximation results
as well is that a okay yeah okay good
okay so now i'm going to get into our
work and uh okay so the takeaway from
the previous slides and including this
mission related work slide is it we have
really great tools already the problem
is just that they're tailored to
specific settings okay so while we have
been able to get some results beyond
what we already know it's really hard to
do this properly okay so the main result
of this paper this is with young and
nikhil i would describe as being a
unified duality approach for a beige in
mechanism design so specifically one
thing we're able to do is we're able to
read arrive the unit demand bound from
Chawla Hartline Kleinberg and the
follow-ups via LP duality and then the
cool thing is we're able to show that
the same exact duel when you specialize
it to the single item setting you get
back meyerson's upper bound and the same
exact duel when you poured it to the
additive bitter setting gives you the
bound that was used in these works of
hardened Nissan and follow-up work ok so
why these um so while these three
approaches used to be very different we
now understand them a lot better they
come from exactly the same duality
approach ok i just want to point out
quickly the approach does apply more
generally for instance to settings like
these but i'm not going to talk about
them in this talk I'm just going to
restrict attention to the additive
bitter ok so what am I going to do the
rest of the talk so i'll just try and
briefly show you where duality comes
from so like i said i'm going to be
really light on proof details but i'll
just try and show you why do ality comes
into the picture at all i'll try and
show you what the dual solutions look
like and then i'll just stayed some
recent applications of this approach
that are outside this paper ok so just
to keep the talk a little bit simple
let's assume that the population has
finite support this is just so that i
can use you know like LP duality instead
of continuous LP duality for simplicity
ok so where does it come from it comes
from LP duality so what I would like to
do on this slide is show you an LP that
finds the optimal mechanism ok so I'm
not going to worry about solving this LP
in poly time but i just want to show you
that you can if you can solve it find
the optimal mechanism ok so what does
what variables is Yelp you have so it
has a variable for every possible bid
profile and then its doors for every
bitter I in item J the probability the
bitter i gets item J on this bid profile
I'm going to also just introduce these
helper variables pi IJ of VI so this is
just going to be for every bitter I for
every item J if bitter I juices the
report VI what is the probability in
expectation over the mech the mechanism
and in the other bidders valuations that
they receive item J NPI of VI is going
to store for every bit or I and every
vector they might report the price paid
by this bitter when they report this
type in expectation over the same
okay so if these variables aren't clear
they might become clearer through the
constraints ok so what constraints is a
truthful mechanism need to satisfy so
first it has to be truthful what does
that mean it means it for adney bitter
so it means it for any bitter for any
true valuation vector they should prefer
to tell the truth then to tell any lie
okay so the left-hand side of this is
just exactly computing the utility of a
bitter with valuation vector V I for
telling the truth and this is computing
their expected utility for telling the
live VI prime we also need to guarantee
that the mechanism is feasible in the
sense that it never allocates any item
more than once on any bid profile this
is really easy it's just making sure
that some probabilities sum up to it
most one and then we just need to
guarantee that these helper variables
are computed correctly so if you didn't
follow the definition up here this is
another way to define the helper
variables ok and then overall truthful
and feasible mechanisms we want to find
the one that maximizes the expected
revenue and this is just a linear
function that does that it sums over
every bitter over every type the
probability that the bidder has this
valuation vector times the price they
would pay condition on that ok sorry ok
so what I want to point out is that we
saw from the previous examples that the
solution to this LP could be really
messy and counterintuitive right and I
want to claim that the only reason that
happens is because of these truthfulness
constraints ok so let's do a quick
sanity check so if we didn't have these
truthfulness constraints so if I just
remove them and I said I still want to
solve this Opie then this is really easy
to do right so that's because the price
variables actually don't show up in any
of the other constraints so I can just
pick one and set at the plus infinity
and now I've solved the LP ok I want to
claim actually something even a little
bit stronger oh sorry this is what I
just excuse me what I just said out loud
that actually it would be easy to
optimize any linear function ok and so
why is that so clearly if any of these
multipliers for the price variables is
nonzero then I can just set the
corresponding price to either plus or
minus infinity and if all of these mole
pliers happen to be 0 then I claim that
this optimization is also easy okay so
why is this is because the only
constraints i have on the X I JS is it
for every bit profile the probability
that item J is allocated should sum up
to it most one so if I want to maximize
a linear function of the X I JS I should
just on every bid profile find the
bitter with the highest multiplier for
item J that's non negative and give that
person the item okay whoops okay so
that's what I just said out loud this is
a text okay so what's the point the
point is it the truthfulness constraints
are the only annoying is the only
annoying part of this LP and what we
should do to get better intuition is we
should move them to the objective with
Lagrangian multipliers okay so if you're
not comfortable with Lagrangian
multiplier is the only thing you need to
know for this talk is it if I give you a
set of nonzero Lagrangian multipliers
for each of these constraints and move
them to the objective then any set of
nonzero multipliers gives you an upper
bound on how good the solution to this
hope you can be ok so now ok so now
let's see what what do the dual
solutions look like ok so I've drawn
this picture let me you know just tell
you what's in this picture first before
telling you how it relates to the
multipliers correct I think I uh yes not
that yeah sorry sorry not negative yes
that was just a typo I might have
written non 0 elsewhere where I mean not
negative I never mean non zero I always
mean not negative yeah ok so what's in
this picture I've drawn these so for all
bidders I I want to draw a picture that
looks like this there's going to be a
source in a sink and I want to draw also
a node for every possible valuation
vector the bitter I might have to make
this picture manageable I've only drawn
to ok and now I've drawn edges between
different nodes and I've put some labels
on them ok so these red edges that I've
drawn correspond to the Lagrangian
multipliers for the truthfulness
constraints so what I mean by that is
whatever Lagrangian multipliers you
wanted to use I want you to write them
on these edges so you'll remember that
there is a truthfulness constraint
saying that bitter I with type VI 1 did
not want to lie and say
I to instead whatever multiplier you
have for that constraint I want you to
put that on the edge from V I 12 v i2
okay these black edges are fixed so they
so when you draw this picture the black
edges do not depend on the choice of
Lagrangian multipliers and the green
edges you can set arbitrarily but non
negative yeah ok so I'm lemo they were
able to show and I'm not going to prove
this this is really just algebraic
manipulation is it a set of Lagrangian
multipliers for this LP happen to yield
a finite upper bound if and only if when
you draw the above picture you get a
flow ok so what I mean by that is if
when you draw this picture every
interior node has flow in equal to flow
out and all of the edge weights are
non-negative ok and the intuition is
just that you know it turns out that if
this picked this picture is a flow if
and only if the coefficient for all the
price variables in the Lagrangian
objective happens to be 0 ok so as fine
if you don't completely understand
what's going on but I just wanted to
give you some intuition as to what the
dual solutions look like ok so now I
told you how to get a finite upper bound
let's see what the upper bound actually
looks like so it has a statement of the
following form which is it for any
truthful mechanism the revenue you get
from that mechanism is upper bounded by
that mechanisms expected virtual welfare
so let me parse what this isn't
connected to virtual welfare ok so i'll
define this variable v IJ of VI it's
defined according to this formula and
now what is this something this is just
summing over every profile over every
agent and every item their virtual value
for that item times the probability that
they get it on this profile ok it's not
important that you know remember even
parse this definition all I want you to
take away from it is that it does depend
on the Lagrangian multipliers so
different settings of Lagrangian
multipliers give you different virtual
transformations which gives you
different upper bounds on how good the
revenue can be
and the other thing if you're familiar
with meyerson's virtual values or if you
remember the definition of regularity
from earlier in the slide or earlier in
the talk you'll just notice some
similarity between this form in that
form but I don't want to get into more
detail about that ok so again just to go
over the interpretation in text is that
every valuation vector has a virtual
value for every item it's according to
this formula which depends on the
Lagrangian multipliers the revenue of
any truthful mechanism is upper bounded
by its virtual welfare and again just to
give you intuition for this right-hand
side its maximized when you give item J
to the highest non-negative virtual
value for item J on every bid profile ok
and this is the last slide I have about
this there's also just to remind you so
on one thing we do in the paper is we
find a specific flow such that when you
take the corresponding virtual values in
the unit than the single item setting
you get back meyerson's virtual values
when you port the same flow into the
unit demand setting you get exactly the
bound used by chawla Hartline Kleinberg
and when you take this same flow into
the additive bitter setting you get the
bound use by hardness on ok so this is
on the last slide I have ok so in this
paper we actually didn't really prove
any new results right so the point of
the paper was to understand much better
a lot of results that were important
from the past ten years or so ok so
personally I think that was a worthwhile
use of our time but you might think that
this is really only worthwhile to do if
it lets you prove something new in the
future ok so this slide is mostly just
to convince you that we were able to use
this approach to prove something new
maybe I won't read each of these three
in detail this is the last slide so I'll
leave it up but i just want to point out
that the point is that all three of
these directions were places that we
didn't have a starting point previously
ok so what this duality framework
provides us is a starting point and from
the starting point we can then use you
know like domain specific techniques to
get each of these three results
ok so that's everything I have thanks a
lot for listening does ironing under the
picture dis important um Syria you
recover Myerson yeah so I so did ya the
answer is just yes um I don't know that
I can give a better explanation online
but um yes it were the best thing to do
is to give it to the bitter with the
highest virtual value so right so
basically here when I'm saying virtual
values I really mean iron virtual value
so like I tried to maybe I was too
subtle I tried to include the bar when I
was talking about Myers and virtual
values earlier I guess I could have put
a bar here too but um that means like
here when I say virtual values you
should read I you should read iron
virtual values if you know what that
means so these will be non negative
these will mmm the fees no they will
happen to be no it's not the case that
for any flow they are non decreasing for
like for the one we come up with they
will happen to always be non decreasing
yeah
is it correct to say that the Lagrangian
t players give you some sort of relaxed
truthfulness condition yes so one way to
think of it is that if you restrict
attention okay so some Lagrangian
multipliers are going to be 0 some are
going to be a strictly positive the ones
that have a what is it the ones that
have a multiplier of zero is basically
as if they were dropped completely so
another thing we learn is you know for
this specific flow it doesn't actually
set it many of the Lagrangian
multipliers are 0 so we learned
something else which is it actually all
of these upper bounds we didn't even
need all of the truthfulness constraints
in the first place it was enough to
consider relax truthfulness condition
and that would still give an upper bound
that can be targeted by these mechanisms
the flow as you compute which like most
much place do you choose yeah so the
only nonzero multipliers are ones for
where bitter with valuation lehigh does
not want to lie by under reporting their
value for their favorite item by the
minimal amount possible those are so for
every bitter there is one lie that we
won one lie that we make sure they don't
want to tell and it's exactly that lie
and those are the only ones you need to
get any of these upper bounds
do we know what distribution for which
these inequalities actual tides which
inequality like maybe one on this slide
are one on the previous actually which
one if the inquiry is tight if equality
does that basically mean that you don't
need I really know so yeah okay okay so
i think it was hard to use good
terminology that was not overburdened
some for non-experts and intelligible
for experts so you should interpret this
as already having been ironed so does
that make sense for which we don't need
I ready so I guess I'm just pushing back
that it's I subject to me using poor
language I don't think it's a
well-defined question because we don't
have a defined flow like our flow is
defined already having ironed so it's
not like there's a natural does that
make sense like it's not like oh there's
a natural virtual value that you have to
iron there's just one virtual value that
you really should think of as being an
iron virtual value but I just dropped
the iron because I didn't want to use
too many words sure yeah yeah so this is
inequality always holds for any flow
Curt in order to get optimality you need
to find a mechanism marriage equality
and for that only ironing property works
so that's kind of the correct if that
didn't answer i'm happy to just tell you
more yep